SpaceX is gearing up for a crucial test
that could help send astronauts to space
from US soil for the first time in
nearly a decade the unmanned crew Dragon
capsule will intentionally break off
from the falcon 9 rocket minutes after
liftoff tomorrow the in-flight R abort
test aims to prove SpaceX can return
astronauts to safety in the event of an
emergency
mark Strassmann is at the Kennedy Space
Center in Florida where this morning's
test had to be scrubbed mark good
morning good morning Dana choppy seas
with the issue which might have
prevented SpaceX from recovering its
capsule they're gonna try again tomorrow
here's what's supposed to happen they're
willing to destroy a rocket in order to
prove that it's on board escape system
really does work essentially what
happens is 84 seconds after launch they
turn off the engines of the rocket
aerodynamic forces will probably break
apart that rocket but by then the
capsule should have been thrown to
safety it's the final milestone before
SpaceX starts launching astronauts
SpaceX
nobody is counting on SpaceX is escape
system more than these two astronauts
Bob Behnken and Doug Hurley their space
shuttle veterans training to fly first
on SpaceX's new ship called crew dragon
a huge advantage of the capsule design
typically as you have an abort escape
capability throughout the Ovilus which
we did not have in shuttle you genuinely
believe if something goes wrong you've
got options
absolutely absolutely if the Falcon 9
rocket ever has an in-flight crisis crew
dragons escape system is designed to
fire eight onboard engines and push the
capsule and astronauts away to safety
parachutes would land them in the
Atlantic and we have sluggish down even
reliable Rockets can have a bad day lit
up 15 months ago NASA astronaut Nick
Hague and Russian cosmonaut Alexei of
Chinon were riding a Russian Soyuz to
the space station two minutes into
flight their rocket malfunctioned and
all of a sudden there was this violent
shaking side-to-side and the alarms
going off and I see a red light that's
lit up and it says that you've had an
emergency with the booster the launch
escape system saved their lives
we were ripped away from the rocket
while it's disintegrating and continuing
to burn and pulled away to safety you
realize in that moment this could have
been really bad the launch of crew is
something that we've been working
towards for for 17 years last March
SpaceX flew a successful uncrewed test
flight to the ISS but a month later that
spaceship exploded during a ground test
it set the company back months while
it's disappointing it also can be a real
gift to the final design and we totally
Frank you know if there hasn't been some
hardware that blowed up we grew up on
the test and I don't think you tested it
hard enough that's the reality Boeing is
the other company hired by NASA
it's uncrewed spacecraft failed to dock
with his space station during a test
flight last month the onboard computer
mistimed the mission sequence NASA's
administrator Jim bridenstine told us
neither company will fly astronauts
until it's safe these vehicles have have
never flown humans before so is there
risk here yes are we doing everything we
can to mitigate it absolutely they're
gonna try again tomorrow morning when
the new launch window opens at 8:00 a.m.
if all goes well if the test flight is a
success spacex could start launching
astronauts as soon as March Michelle
all righty mark looks like you're having
a great time down these uncrewed
missions are so important remember there
were what five seven controlled landings
on the moon right before Neil Armstrong
did yes and the one before Neil
Armstrong was was was was it Gemini 8 it
was Apollo 8 some of the man some but
the one with the wager and some of the
other missions that were unmanned okay
you